on n'est pas là pour bloquer qui n'en
est pas à vendre
donc pas question de rentrer dans une
majorité présidentielle pas question
d'un an le gouvernement une chose est
certaine c'est qu'à l'assemblée
rien ne se fera
avec monsieur mélenchon
rien cependant avec madame le pen
et nous on a les idées très claires sur
ce qu'il faut faire en matière de
retraite avec de la justice en matière
de sécurité plus de fermeté et en termes
de pouvoir d'achat on n'oublie pas les
gens qui travaillent et donc maintenant
ça fait très clairement aussi un must
de dire qu'on n'est pas des bloqueurs et
on n'est pas à vendre vous vous
retrouvez au centre du jeu finalement
t rien ne se fera sans aurait l'air à
l'assemblée et au sénat la majorité
des fêtes vous en êtes à votre
préliminaire l'importance et ne pas
travailler avec la
avec maintenant je rassure j'ai été très
clair vous êtes arrivé habitués à cela
comment parler avec votre avis est ce
que c'est une manière de dire par là
c'est aux jeunes il est temps que les
jeunes prennent davantage de
responsabilités très clairement à tous
les niveaux et vous allez les aider et
les enfants
a été faite au siècle d'expérience
davantage leur place
[Musique]